how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the mcu
and typically when i do a venom video i
say
and also the spumc the sony picture
universe of
marvel characters but it appears that
the two universes
are colliding even more so than we've
seen already happen
and today it looks like we have some
very good evidence suggesting that tom
hall and spider-man will indeed be in
venom 2
let there be carnage this has been
speculated for a long time and of course
it's something that all of the fans want
to see
especially since carnage is going to be
the main villain of venom 2
fans have been wanting a venom
spider-man team up to defeat him and
although we're not sure what the plot is
going to hold
for us it does look like tom holland
will be at least making some sort of a
cameo as spider-man and i'll talk about
this new proof that we have but first
big congratulations to youtube user
tyler ben for being the winner of the
tony stark funko pop just email me in
the email in my description and i'll get
you your prize and for this week we have
a really cool funko pop we're giving
away a zombie
hulk funko pop all you have to do to
enter subscribe like the video and leave
a comment down below and thank you to
heroes hideout.com for providing the
funko pop
so how we got today's news about the
possible spider-man
venom crossover is a little bit weird
but bear with me because it does have a
lot of credit to it
yesterday it was discovered that party
city and
amazon have both posted listings for an
officially
licensed costume associated with the
upcoming movie
venom let there be carnage and both of
these listings and costumes
say that they are specifically for venom
two now this is a little bit weird but
these are officially
licensed costumes for venom two and of
course
party city and amazon do have to make
sure that they are
officially licensed from marvel and sony
so these are
very official costumes from venom 2 and
what's really interesting is that the
costume for
venom shows the white spider emblem on
the chest
now i'm sure as many of you recall tom
hardy's venom does not have the spider
emblem on his chest
what venom had on his chest in the movie
was more sort of just like
white veins but in this costume that
remember is officially licensed by
marvel
4 venom 2 specifically he does have this
white spider emblem
on his chest it's very noticeable it's
very defined
and this is coming from marvel so that's
not an error now again since it is
specifically listed for venom 2 that
leads us to believe that spider-man
will come in contact with a venom at
some point during venom let there be
carnage
after all originally venom bonds with
peter parker and that's why he gets the
white spider emblem on the symbiote in
the first venom film he doesn't have
that symbiote because he's
never ran into spider-man in the film
venom just arrived on earth and eddie
brock was one of the first people that
the symbiote came in contact with
but since it has the spider emblem in
this photo of the costume that leads us
to believe that at some point in time
tom hardy's eddie brock and tom
holland's peter parker are going to
cross
paths and it won't be just peter parker
it will be peter parker as
spider-man because why else would he get
the emblem if he didn't come in contact
with
spider-man so again we're unsure of the
plot and we're not really sure if this
is going to be a cameo from spider-man
or if he's going to play a decent role
in the movie now obviously a lot of the
movie is going to focus on
venom it is his movie and of course
cletus cassidy and
carnage and they did list a carnage
costume as well now it isn't really a
first look or anything like that because
it is a costume but it's the same thing
it's officially licensed by marvel so we
do kind of get a look at maybe what to
kind of expect for carnage again it's a
costume but it looks pretty similar to
venom except it has a bit more
veins on it and the fingers are actually
super sharp which is definitely a
carnage trait so it's good to know that
the movie is going to stick true to that
but again we won't try to dissect too
much about it because it's a costume but
this is a great find and it definitely
gives us
hope that tom holland's spider-man is
going to be in venom 2. we do know that
sony
wanted tom holland to be in the first
venom film marvel studios said no
because they didn't want people to
confuse the different universes
however it looks like the two universes
are kind of starting to collide the
morbius trailer was a really
big hint at that and now in spider-man 3
the multiverse is coming and a
spider-verse has come in as well so
perhaps marvel and sony
are planning a really really large
universe for spider-man venom and a
bunch of other characters as well
at least we can all hope that they are
but in the comments down below give me
your best
guess on what you think spider-man's
role in venom let there be carnage is
going to be
and don't forget to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
spider-man and
venom news don't forget to like this
video and check out heroeshideout.com
for awesome marvel merch for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof